[Music]
born on the Big Island of Hawaii chefs
Sheldon Simeon began cooking for his
family at an early age after high school
he headed straight to culinary training
and began his career soon earning
national acclaim as a fan favorite on
TVs Top Chef after taking an executive
position in Maui he was sooo named one
of Hawaii's best chefs
last year he opened up his very first
solo restaurant Maui's Tin Roof where he
serves up local favorites and he'll open
a second solo project nearby later this
year
chef Sheldon Simeon Aloha welcome to the
dish you come the longest way it was
definitely a long canoe ride tell us
about the table oh well we've got to
spread up Hawaii stuff so this is
pulling from my Filipino roots bibingka
and unset' noodles here is our chicken
sandwich from tin roof which we serve a
hundred of those a day Wow the the
seafood of Hawaii is amazing so we've
got ahi poke you there Luna for those W
don't know it is and then we've got some
swordfish with chili oil over the top
and bok choy that's stir-fried and then
just a fresh tofu watercress salad
Guillen it looks incredible you know one
of the things that I love about Hawaiian
cuisine is its polyglot cuisine right
it's an immigrant cuisine it comes from
all over the places starting from the
beginning you know it is those uh Native
Hawaiians that came from the Marquesas
and traveled this way I've made Hawaii
their home and then all of those
different layers of the immigrants like
the Filipinos and the Japanese and
Portuguese all coming for the to work on
the plantations the sugar cane
plantations all bringing their culture
and all kind of coming together to make
I think they see it one of the most a
sea as we see in front of a new wave of
chefs in Hawaii is that where you took
your inspiration from all those
different places yeah well just being
born and raised in Hawaii you know my
neighbor is Japanese and my my other
neighbors Portuguese in the back I
always had kimchi in my refrigerator for
some reason so it's just a part part of
me and my community my food speaks
through my community and my the fly get
my water crest from the farmers the
fisherman is
right down the road my friends uncle and
it's just like kind of all coming
together like that you started cooking
at an early age I know your grandmother
was an influential person and your
family developing your table yes about
that yeah all my greatest memories are
always surrounded by food you know
whether it was cooking in the garage of
my house yeah they're going over to have
a barbecue at the beach it's always food
in the background of it
you opened Tim Revere restaurant just a
few days after you did Top Chef yes
which had to be very challenging yeah I
mean Top Chef called
and okay I kind of accepted it then I
then I told the wife that I was leaving
right after because there wasn't I kind
of don't gonna go on this I'm abandoning
you as basically I said well I had an
amazing staff with myself and my wife is
in oh she's she's a rock star so went on
the show and they they opened up tin
roof yeah just a month after they're
going to the show when you when we talk
about Hawaiian cuisine and produce in
specific it's an island in the middle of
the ocean and so a lot has been flown in
for you know the recent last couple
decades but it sounds like there's a
real movement to get Hawaiian cuisine
back to more sustainable roots yeah yeah
just little over a hundred years ago
that the islands were almost a hundred
percent sustainable being the most
isolated landmass in the world we have
the most perfect climate yes you do no
amazing volcanic soil that anything can
grow there and the chefs again it's
about the community we support of our
farmers of the fishermen and it all
comes together yeah does chef as I asked
you to sign this dish as his custom
program if you could share this Hawaiian
bounty with anyone past or present who
would you share it with I would
definitely share it with my mom my mom
passed right before I started on this
wave of being on television and all of
that so I think she's watching right now
sure she is
she's happy about how delicious that
turnip okay looks there you go chefs
tell Sheldon Simeon thank you and
congratulations Mahalo Mahalo right is
that great that is for more on Sheldon
Simeon and the ditch head to our website
at CBS this morning calm